When people would have asked me the question back in 1993,...
...whether I thought that international accounting standards would ever reach this side of the pond,...
...would ever be used by the SCC without reconciliation to US GAAP,...
...I would have said, "There is not a chance in the world that that's gonna happen."
But what happened was, you know, over the years, again, this groundswell was coming out of Europe principally,...
...big companies were saying, "Why do I have to bother with your crazy standards?"
"We've got this international - based set of standards that are getting better and better."
And by the way, in 2002 in Europe, the European Commission said,...
..."Any company that wants to raise capital in the public markets here"...
..."will have to use international accounting standards for their 2005 financial statements."
That was a huge event...
...and really, I think, represented a tremendous breakthrough for non - US companies.
And I would say that probably one of the biggest reasons why international accounting standards...
...started to gain much more support was Enron.
Now, if you look at the Enron situation,...
...they constructed all these elaborate partnerships and arrangements to get assets off the balance sheet,...
...and US GAAP is famous for having these crazy rules.
You know, you take the amount that you've invested in the company,...
...you divide that by the gross national product and your shoe size,...
...and you end up with an answer to the magical, you know, question.
And lo and behold, Enron, the bottom fell out of that.
And, you know, suddenly, US GAAP didn't look so much like the gold standard anymore.
And in fact, there was a huge backlash around all these cumbersome rules and how you get,...
...you know, as soon as you create an accounting rule,...
...you'll have a sea of investment bankers that come out of the woodwork...
...and try to sell you a product that will help you to navigate around those rules.
And that's what did in Enron.